hey guys my name is Jess matal it is a
25th of August today and we're back
bringing new games but news from the
Sydney office where the weather is
reliably lovely every single day of the
year kinda first off the PlayStation
Network came under a distributed
denial-of-service attack yes today and
the saga has just gotten even weirder
hackers hit the service with D dos
attacks designed to pull it off line but
on the plus side sony says they don't
believe any personal information was
compromised not only with a playstation
network and sony entertainment network
affected but it turns out that the same
group responsible for that also made a
bomb threat for a flight carrying sony
online entertainment president john
smedley regardless of how sony managed
to get so heavily on somebody's bad side
their services are back up and running
now next up we've got some super smash
brothers news for you to tide you over
until we can get the game into applause
all little white plumber gloves later
this year and full of leaks roster
videos which have since been removed and
a bunch of previously unseen images
suggest that three brand new characters
are joining the ones we already know and
suspect will be wailing on each other in
various platform the arenas very soon
Nintendo hasn't confirmed anything
official but it seems like the dog from
duck hunt Bowser jr. and Schultz from
Xenoblade Chronicles will be included in
the brawler you can check out the full
list of 37 officially announced fighters
on site as well as the ones we're now
suspecting could have earned a place on
the roster there's also a bunch of
trophies that have leaked if you want to
get a head start on what you'll start
filling your virtual cabinet with when
the game releases last up in a story
that is one hundred percent confirmed
amazon have bought twitch for 1 billion
dollars which is a lot even though all
the buzz was around google picking up
the streaming service through its
youtube subsidiary it seems amazon must
have swept in just under the wire the
mega company have splashed out roughly
nine hundred and seventy million for all
outstanding shares in
honey CEO of which Emmett shear
commented on the deal saying we chose
Amazon because they believe in a
community they share our values and
long-term vision and they want to help
us get there faster we're keeping most
everything the same our office our
employees our brand and most importantly
our independence start with Amazon
support will have the resources to bring
you an even better twit and your
question of the day is who would you
have wanted to acquire twitch or are you
happy with amazon making the deal that
is it for me today thanks for tuning in
as always i'll be back same time
tomorrow and I promise I'll never leave
you again probably